do you think one day we'll build an AI
system that we a person can fall in love
with and it would love them back like in
the movie her for example yeah although
she she kind of didn't fall in love with
him
or she fell in love with like a million
other people something like that
so you're the jealous type I see we
humans at the judge yes
so I do believe that we can design
systems where people would fall in love
with their robot with their AI partner
that I do believe because it's actually
and I won't I don't like to use the word
manipulate but as we see there are
certain individuals that can be
manipulated if you understand the
cognitive science about it right alright
so I mean if you could think of all
close relationship and love in general
as a kind of mutual manipulation that
dance the human dance I mean many
parishioners a negative connotation and
I don't like to use that word
particularly I guess another way to
phrase is you're getting at is it could
be algorithmic eyes or something it
could be the relationship building part
can yeah yeah I mean just think about it
there we have and I don't use dating
sites but from what I heard there are
some individuals that have been dating
that have never saw each other right in
fact there's a show I think that tries
to I weed out fake people like there's a
show that comes out right because like
people start faking like what's the
difference of that person on the other
end being an AI agent right and having a
communication are you building a
relationship remotely like there there's
no reason why that can't happen in terms
of human robot interaction was a what
role you've kind of mentioned with data
emotion being can be problematic if not
implemented well I suppose what role
does emotion some other human-like
things the imperfect things come into
play here for a good human robot
interaction and something like love yes
so in this case and you had asked can I
a I agent love a human back
I think they can emulate love back right
and so what does that actually mean it
just means that if you think about their
programming they might put the other
person's needs in front of theirs and
certain situations right you look at
think about it as a return on investment
like was my return on investment as part
of that equation that person's happiness
you know has some type of you know
algorithm weighting to it and the reason
why is because I care about them right
that's the only reason right but if I
care about them and I show that then my
final objective function is length of
time of the engagement right so you can
think of how to do this actually quite
easily and so but that's not love well
so that's the thing it I think it
emulates love because we don't have a
classical definition of love right but
and we don't have the ability to look
into each other's minds to see the
algorithm and I mean I guess what I'm
getting at is is it possible that
especially if that's learned especially
if there's some mystery and black box
nature to the system how is that you
know how is it any different I was any
different and in terms of sort of if the
system says I'm cautious I'm afraid of
death and it does indicate that it loves
you another way to sort of phrase it be
curious to see what you think do you
think there'll be a time when robots
should have rights you've kind of
phrased the robot in a very roboticist
way it's just a really good way but
saying okay well there's an objective
function and I can see how you can
create a compelling human robot
interaction experience that makes you
believe that the robot cares for your
needs and even something like loves you
but what if the robot says please don't
turn me off what if the robot starts
making you feel like there's an entity
of being a soul there right do you think
there'll be a future hopefully you won't
laugh too much at this but the
they do ask for rights so I can see a
future if we don't address it in the
near term where these agents as they
adapt and learn could say hey this
should be something that's fundamental I
hopefully think that we would address it
before it gets to that point you think
so that you think as a bad future is
like what is that a negative thing where
they ask or being discriminated against
I guess it depends on what role have
they attained at that point right and so
if I think about now careful what you
say because the robots 50 years from now
I'll be listening to this and you'll be
on TV saying this is what roboticists
used to believe and so this is my and as
I said I have a bias lens and my robot
friends will understand that yes but so
if you think about it
and I actually put this in kind of fee
as a robot assists you don't necessarily
think of robots as human with human
rights but you could think of them
either in the category of property or
you can think of them in the category of
animals right and so both of those have
different types of of Rights so animals
have their own rights as as a living
being but you know they can't vote they
can't write they can be euthanized but
as humans if we abuse them we go to jail
like right so they do have some rights
that protect them but don't give them
the rights of like citizenship and then
if you think about property property the
rights are associated with the person
right so if someone vandalizes your
property or steals your property like
there are some rights but it's
associated with the person who owns that
if you think about it back in the day
and if you remember we talked about you
know how society has changed women were
property right they were not
thought of as having rights they were
thought of as property of like their
yeah assaulting a woman meant assaulting
the property of somebody else's but
exactly and so what I envision is is
that we will establish some type of norm
at some point but that it might evolve
right like if you look at women's rights
now like there are some countries that
don't have in the rest of the world is
like why that makes no sense right and
so I do see a world where we do
establish some type of grounding it
might be based on property rights it
might be based on animal rights and if
it evolves that way I think we will have
this conversation at that time because
that's the way our society traditionally
has evolved
you